[Music]
[Applause]
one hello darkness hello children
it is I the darkness within so you know
how life is like kind of bad well what
are you gonna do about that hmm I mean
there's a few things you can do first
you could work to improve yourself and
make the world a better place that's
probably the most effective approach
eventually but the problem is that it's
hard and I don't like things that are
hard because when you do things that are
hard you have to feel bad now so that
you can feel good later
and I don't want to feel good later I
want to feel good now and if you want to
feel good now well you have a couple
options the first is of course to do
drugs and I've tried that I spent most
of my 20s on the threshold of alcoholism
but it turns out that's not a cute look
for me it's not my vibe so what I do now
when I feel the darkness coming is what
any respectable woman would do I take a
xanax and lie on the floor for a couple
hours
is that a pee under my mattress your
majesty or is it another xanax I left
under the throw rug now the problem with
doing drugs is that when the drugs wear
off you feel bad again in fact you
probably feel worse so where do we go
from here
well how about music you feel bad you
want to listen to sad music because sad
music makes you cry and crying feels
good
it's like an orgasm for sad people and
why settle for less than the official
meme song of sadness the sound of
silence by Simon and Garfunkel you know
I'm pretty sure there's another xanax
under this throw rug hello darkness my
old friend
but in the memes you only hear the first
10 seconds of the song
you only hear hello darkness my old
friend and that's the very sad first 10
seconds of a song which is good because
if you're making songs for sad people
it's important to establish your sadness
cred up front because sad people don't
like happy songs when you're sad happy
songs make you feel like you're being
[ __ ] and so we're ten seconds into
the song hello darkness my old friend
the key is d sharp minor the saddest
with all keys but when we get to the
next line because of vision softly
creeping something happens let's listen
come to talk with you again because a
vision softly creeping ah what was that
suddenly a major chord an unsuspected
burst of sunlight through the clouds and
every peach fuzz hair on the back of my
biologically female knack stands on and
halel eyes so the song has enticed me
with its promise of company for misery
and then it has tricked me into feeling
good and that's what I like about art it
takes the standard disappointments and
humiliations of life and cooks them into
something worth getting off the floor
for unfortunately I don't really play
music much anymore because my hands are
too beautiful for instruments and my
singing voice sounds like a man so all I
really have left is what any aspiring
artist with no talent turns to comedy
and I especially like dark comedy you
know comedy about the things in life
that are the most painful to me dark
humor is kind of like a sad song it
takes your worst feelings traumas and
anxieties and twists them into a source
of pleasure and don't all the finest
pleasures come from pain ah a lot of the
time that means joking about topics that
an ordinary life are considered taboo
you know sadness fascism sexual
deviation cult
without the ability to joke and make fun
of my own experiences of self-loathing
substance abuse gender dysphoria
I mean
probably be on the floor right now
looking for that xanax but this puts me
in a difficult situation because I
wanted to defend my sense of humor which
I feel is like the core of my
personality and what keeps me alive but
at the same time I've noticed that a lot
of the people in our culture who are
really big on defending provocative
controversial politically incorrect
comedy are kind of dick nuggets let's
discuss this and by discuss I mean you
said quietly and I'll tell you what to
think - dick nuggets so the year 2016
had just begun and already the most 2016
possible thing was happening Ricky
Gervais is an irreverent bad-boy atheist
comedian was ranting on Twitter for days
and days about how stupid it is that
people are offended by things this is
pretty standard for Ricky Gervais a man
whose personal branding screams I don't
care about your feelings I know what
it's like to be persecuted for my
beliefs I'm too much of a badass rebel
to care what minorities thing but in
January 2016 Ricky Gervais was having an
extra badass irreverent not caring about
your feelings kind of moms why because
he just hosted the Golden Globes and
upset a bunch of people by telling jokes
about all Tran ma Caitlyn Jenner as I
say I'm gonna be nice tonight I've
changed not as much as Bruce Jenner
obviously that's cutting edge material
there Rick very irreverent very
rebellious very bad boy atheist I mean I
do wish you wouldn't dead name trans
people on stage but honestly the joke
wasn't even as transphobic as a lot of
the stuff I've come to just expect from
comics still I'm sure Twitter had a
thing or two to say about it and Ricky
spent the rest of the month tweeting
about how offending people is good
actually and he definitely doesn't care
that people were offended but clearly
Twitter got to him because two years
later he opened his Netflix special with
a 13-minute bit rehashing the incident
and doing a series of even more
irreverent jokes cuz I've always
identified as a chimp right well I am a
chimp
i if I sandwich him I am a chimp pre-op
but
and don't ever dead name me don't ever
call we ricky gervais is again from now
on you call me Bobo does he also
identify as an attack helicopter does he
realize he is doing a meme from 2014 on
stage and a 20 million dollar comedy
special my issue with this joke is that
apart from being extremely passe and
overdone it also doesn't make sense
unless you ignorant ly believe that
trans women are delusional men and even
then it's just not very funny but am i
offended by the joke well I think it's
ignorant misinformed unoriginal and not
very funny and as a great comedian named
Ricky Gervais once said to me an
offensive joke is the one that's lame
badly delivered and not funny enough so
by that measure yes I'd say this idea as
a chimp bit is pretty offensive but I'm
not bringing this old controversy up
because I'm offended I'm bringing it up
because it's just an arbitrary example
of a cycle it seems like our culture
repeats about once a week somebody makes
a joke
some people are offended by the joke and
other people are indignant about the
fact that those people are offended the
cycle usually gets framed as a battle in
a culture war that's supposedly going on
between generations snowflake easily
triggered humorless PZ Cox and badass
edgy nothing off-limits free speech
truth tellers now if this really is a
culture war between two sides than I am
a double agent because I'm a generation
snowflake PC cuck who loves dank edgy
memes and I found myself on both sides
of this type of conflict many many times
so on the one hand when I see the
internet roasting a comedian for some
shitty trans joke my inner snowflake
wants to watch the bastard burn but my
inner edge lady knows how it feels to be
dragged across Twitter over a joke and
as someone who basically writes jokes
about controversial topics for a living
I appreciate how difficult it is to
maintain the mildly sadomasochistic
character of comedy while also keeping
your moral compass from getting too
jittery so what I want to try to do is
step away from the heat of these social
media battles and try to abstract from
them
more general philosophical questions
what is the purpose of comedy what is it
that makes comedy good or bad does good
comedy punch up and speak truth to power
does it bring light to some aspect of
the human condition is it as Aristotle
said the imitation of worse than average
German or is it simply anything anyone
laughs at for whatever reason well I
don't think there's a single objective
answer I mean comedy is pretty
subjective but we can probably reach
some kind of understanding by discussing
this right and by we again I I do mean
me the rest of you can keep your goddamn
mouth shut
free straw man so as a trans woman up
here discussing why I don't think Ricky
Gervais is trans jokes are funny a lot
of haters and losers out there are
probably gonna try to strawman me did
you just assume the straw person says
people have liked to trans jokes and
they're both so bad here's the straw
person's [ __ ] straw person one you
hate free speech and are trying to
silence comedians I'm not trying to
silence anyone comedians can say
whatever they want on stage and I can
say whatever I want about them straw
person - you just can't take the heat
when the joke's on you I transitioned on
YouTube making controversial political
content all the while and I read the
comments my hate taking capacity is
among the highest of all time of course
I do not have the internalized
self-loathing that has damaged my psyche
irreparably but sweetie
who doesn't strawperson 3 you think no
one should be allowed to joke about
trans people I invented joking about
trans people never heard of the
mouthfeel I'm that tram that's right if
I die tomorrow my legacy will be that I
applied wine-tasting terminology -
fellatio and I accept my
look half my job is telling jokes about
trans people I live for trans jokes I
just don't think this is people are very
good at telling them because they don't
know enough about trans people to know
what the funny things are and being
transgender is honestly the perfect
topic for comedy like you used to live
as one gender and then you became a
different gender every single thing
about that it's absolutely hilarious but
humor is in the details and Ricky
Gervais does not know the details
because he's clearly never been close to
a trans person and that's why he's still
telling these Tinkertoy 2015 caitlyn
jenner jokes and it's too bad cuz I'm
actually starving over here for good
trans comedy and I mean the real dark
stuff - I'm not talking about trans
Rachel on the timeline calling her
hormones teddy skittles no I like the
edgy stuff I like being on the edge hi
my name is Natalie win and I enjoy
edging now there is one recent work of
trans comedy that I'd like to share with
you because when you're doing art
criticism it helps to have positive as
well as negative examples and the
exemplary work I have in mind is one not
a lot of people are talking about yet
but which I have no qualms placing in
the same company as the works of Dante
or Swift I am of course referring to my
sperm bank experience by Gigi gorgeous
if you don't know how gigi is first of
all who even are you do you have no
respect for Legends she's a trans
youtuber like the trans youtuber whose
classic works such as my hemorrhoids and
I had sex with a dog long ago cemented
her status as a comedy icon
but in this critics opinion the crown
jewel of Gigi's OVA is without a doubt
the singular masterpiece my sperm bank
experience let's do a close reading for
Gigi's sperm bank experienced a great
work of literature is never just a text
it is also what the theorist Jean
Jacques visage dupa saw would call a
moment within an intertextual dialectic
love that let us therefore place my
sperm bank experience within its proper
context several months earlier Gigi had
released a video about how she and her
girlfriend were trying to have a child
so far without success and so they went
to see a fertility specialist
apparently gigi was not aware that
taking feminizing hormones can make you
sterile which Carl they tell you like
seven times before you start hormones
like how well move past it a few months
later the notification from my sperm
bank experience shows up on my phone
because that's right I clicked the bell
and immediately I knew I was about to
experience something special the
thumbnail for this video is so much
greater than anything I've ever
conceived of that honestly it makes me
feel like a failure both as a youtuber
and as a woman
the sperm donation cup is labeled with
Gigi's signature the I's are dotted with
hearts and her facial expression LLL
come the video begins with Gigi
explaining that in order to produce a
sample for the clinic she had to stop
taking hormones for three months so I
has it simply agreed I was like fine I
will stop all of my hormones so you know
my [ __ ] can get juicy again and I could
get a good little sample up in here the
sperm bank day arrives she goes to the
clinic approaches the receptionist and I
said yes ma'am I am here to give sperm
from me to be frozen now the doctor
arrives and leads her to the exam room
which she describes with the precision
of Mama flu bear I walk into this room
fluorescent lighting the house I was
like I can see every pore in my arm like
Jesus where they want me to do here and
then the kicker this like leather couch
the back is kind of like angled so I
guess like you can lean and really get
into it or something the doctor offers
her lubrication pornography if needed
and a donation cup Gigi closes the door
and gets to work I get in the mood I got
in this zone and I'm killing it [ __ ]
I'm like I'm gonna give the best sample
ever my kid is gonna be a god-sent child
before I know at the moment has crept up
on me it happened and it's been so long
that it hits the wall behind me and it's
at this moment that glam goddess Gigi
gorges gets up off the leather couch and
attempts to scrape a prodigious quantity
of Gigi jism off the wall of a
fluorescent lit exam room in a desperate
final bid to become a mother and I took
the cup and I was like full-on like
scraping it off the wall because I was
like I'm not gonna let any little drop
go to waste you know I'm here this is
like my moment I try to understand
this video makes me laugh so much it's
really the contrast of style and
substance like it wouldn't be funny if a
masculine person told this story it's
funny because Gigi has this peak
feminine storytelling style in this Real
Housewives diction but the story itself
is about blasting a giant load onto a
wall of a room full of leather and
pornography the dissonance between form
and content is genius and that
dissonance perfectly captures the
absurdity of being transgender with a
comedic incisiveness that Ricky Gervais
is could only dream of I also really
relate to the story because right before
I started hormones I decided to freeze a
sample of my own so I too have a sperm
bank experience and it was exactly like
Gigi describes down to every detail it
is not a dignified moment ladies there
is just no way to feel like a woman
well you're hastily rubbing one out in
an over Latrun designed for men to
ejaculate it I feel so fish right now
for this five minutes in the exam room I
was a man
no I somehow managed to get most of my
sample into the cup but there's a
different absurd detail to my story
the receptionist of the sperm bank saw
on my paperwork that I was depositing
because I was going to start feminizing
hormones and he asked me if there was a
name I preferred he called me and
retrospect he was actually really sweet
and really cute not that anything was
gonna come with that at the time since I
was pray everything and rough around the
edges be honest I was all edges but he
asked me for my preferred name and I
just blurted out Natalie and so this was
actually the first time anyone ever
called me by my biological name and it
went like this the receptionist at the
sperm bank
charged to me and said right this way
Natalie here's a cup for you to bust a
knot in and that's how my life as a
woman began yes now in the end Gigi's
story is actually pretty tragic her
sample wasn't usable she wanted to have
a child with her own DNA but she's been
on hormones too long and she just can't
and that revelation at the end of the
video kind of recontextualizes how you
see the whole story in his ridiculous
image of Gigi scraping ejaculate off the
wall I now see this primal maternal urge
to produce and protects children I see a
mother bird whose chicks have fallen
prematurely from the nest
I see the Virgin Mary cradling her child
I really really thought that I was gonna
have a good sample and I was going to be
able to participate in having a baby
with my DNA but it's just not in the
cards for me and I really wanted to make
this video more positive and funny
because there is nothing I can do and
that's exactly it
that is the darkness 5 the darkness the
darkness is my name for what I consider
the highest form of comedy where you
take your own worst feelings traumas and
anxieties and twist them into a source
of pleasure the darkness is Richard
Pryor running down the street in flames
because he set himself on fire in a COAG
field psycho says the darkness is GG
gorgeous
scraping her own produce jism off the
wall of an exam room in a desperate bid
to save her chance at motherhood if you
can make these low points funny then
you're gonna be okay you're gonna
survive you're gonna make it through
life and I need that now more than ever
because trans experience is in a lot of
ways pretty dark but trans people make
it through because we're good humoured
and strong as [ __ ] pretty soon I'm gonna
have to stop hormones before an
operation and I'm terrified of that
what's gonna happen to me when I stop
hormones am I gonna become a man again
cuz I don't know if I can handle that
I'm thinking about names though like
maybe Nathan or Jayden I can't see
myself as a Jaden see I've gotta have my
little jokey jokes or I don't think I
could make it through this like when I
have bottom surgery I am absolutely
going to constantly refer to it as my
sex change operation because it makes me
laugh it brings me joy calling it gender
confirmation surgery brings me no joy
now it's important to notice that just
because it doesn't make me laugh doesn't
mean it's a politically correct
euphemism gender confirmation is a more
accurate term than sex change because
you're literally not changing your sex
that's not what surgery does but ng
people have their own kind of political
correctness with a mistake edginess for
honesty accuracy and directness but
these are very different things for
example George Carlin has a classic bit
about euphemisms that has some great
moments but also some moments that are
way off base
for example content wording ablest slur
they say they're going to pre-board
those pass
in need of special assistance cripples
simple honest direct language so look I
understand the aesthetic preference for
simple honest direct language and the
repulsion toward verbose bureaucratic
jargon that's why so much of the rest of
this bit is so good but the word he just
used is literally a slur so I wonder if
what you're being honest about is your
feelings toward disabled people because
the phrase passengers in need of special
assistance is a little wordy sure but in
this situation it's actually more
accurate since it also includes the
elderly the pregnant anyone in need of
assistance boarding so I call my gender
confirmation surgery getting a sex
change not because it's more direct and
honest but specifically because it's
inaccurate and outdated and that makes
me laugh
not because I'm a fearless truth teller
but because I'm a bad person and I get
to call it my sex change operation but
sis people don't get to call it that
because it's my darkness not yours
get your own darkness when ricky gervais
jokes about trans people he's being a
hack cuz he knows nothing of our
darkness and when someone tries to joke
about something that they're totally
ignorant of the result is usually clumsy
awkward and not very funny what I'd
really like to see is if ricky gervais
stook all that irreverent bad-boy
derisive nests and turned it within
because within is where the darkness
lies sinks self deprecation
self-deprecating humor is my personal
favorite because as a lazy selfish
craning attention [ __ ] who looks like a
slightly more passable Ann Coulter with
a voice of a tropical bird there's a lot
of material here to work with but
especially when it comes to the trans
jokes there is a faction of the trans
community that is not amused by the
buffoonery that goes on on this channel
I think the objection to it is best
summed up by the comic Hannah Gatsby who
and her stand-up special Nanette said
that when self deprecation comes from
someone who exists in the margins it's
not humility it's humiliation and to be
honest I felt a little called out by
that I put myself down in order to speak
in order to seek permission to speak and
she's not wrong like that is
how this works in order to gain an
audience as a trans person you have to
demonstrate with sis people call self
awareness that is you have to signal
that you see yourself the way the
audience sees you which can mean looking
at yourself with a pretty merciless gaze
and of course I'm happy to do that
because I have no self respect and
laughter is the only way to numb the
pain but the terrible thing about being
a not normal with an audience is that
you don't just get to be yourself
because whether you like it or not
people will see you as a representative
of the community oh so because of that
responsibility which I never asked for I
have to balance out the self deprecation
with a lot of positive messaging about
my people and that way the dark shocks
function as a spoonful of sugar to help
the feminine penis go down but even
without the group representation issue
it definitely is possible to take self
deprecation too far as I said I have
been diagnosed with an incurable
edginess of temperament and I sometimes
do feel suffocated by the safe space
rules of a lot of trans spaces even
though those spaces are there for good
reason and a lot of people need them but
sometimes this atmosphere of everything
and everyone is solid all the time
no uncomfortable questions may be asked
any self deprecation is a sign of
traumatic internalized bigotry I just
need to get out of there for a while and
find a place where I can relax and be my
edgy self I need a safe space for my
edginess where I can just blurt out
whatever stupid question or joke comes
to mind without being afraid that I'm
gonna inflict horrible trauma
I never went around me so I call up
another transsexual edge lady you know
Kiki accuse each other of being cross
dressers and just laugh it all off and
it's so so cathartic to do that but it
does have to be done in moderation
because there can come a point where
you're picking at the wound and
of numbing it and it mostly has to be
done in private because in public you
have to worry about how this people will
interpret it and so you have to find a
way to be self-deprecating without
abandoning all social responsibility yes
if there was ever a phrase that
instantly deadens all after its social
responsibility but since its kind of the
central topic of the comedy culture war
I should probably say something about it
even though believe me I'd much rather
go back to jabbering about my sex change
7 the eternal tension so what is a
comedians job what is a comedian
supposed to do
I suppose my ideal comedian is one who
is perfectly able to balance the tension
between shitposting and snowflake eree
and this is an eternal tension it must
never be resolved it is a tightrope I
have devoted my life to walking see if
the tension collapses into pure
snowflake eree you've got a moralist who
might say that a comedians purpose is to
promote justice by punching up by
speaking truth to power by exposing the
flaws of bigoted mindsets and so on and
these are all very admirable goals but
they leave out what I think is the
essential purpose of comedy which is to
be funny to surprise to shock to make
people laugh it's kind of like how some
art and media critics only ever evaluate
a work based on whether or not it's
socially progressive and don't seem to
really think about aesthetic pleasure
very much which to me is the reason why
art exists in the first place but then
again I am a hedonistic bushwa decadent
and should probably be sent to the
guillotine at once just let me do my
makeup first so that when they hold my
head up everyone can see my beat and
their wings all fly to the Bastille also
someone please post the video to my
Instagram cuz that's gonna get a lot of
engagement so the opposite of the Pierre
snowflake is the pure shet poster who
might say that a comedians purpose is to
make an audience laugh by any means
necessary but that seems kind of
barbaric since like if a guard in a
prison camp is torturing an inmate and
the other guards are laughing does that
count as comedy is a war crime funny
well according to the Geneva Convention
it's hilarious the thing is I don't
think many comedians actually believe in
a completely
holistic vision of comedy I think they
sometimes pretend to when they're trying
to evade criticism I mean take even the
edgiest of white guy comics and listen
to the way they talk about their heroes
Lenny Bruce or George Carlin there's
always an element of admiration for
bravery risk subversion truth-telling
in other words there's a concern there
for what is virtuous and what is true
not just for what makes people laugh so
maybe before we can even talk about
what's funny we have to have a level of
shared agreement about what is true and
what is morally right my objection to
Ricky Gervais is trans jokes is not just
that they're not funny I think he's
wrong about trans people and I think his
ignorance is infectious I think he's
stirring up bigoted sentiments in his
audience which has the consequence of
making the world slightly scarier for
people like me and too this is edginess
at its worst just a privileged person
with a platform punching down at a
politically besieged group he
understands nothing about and that's
what happens when the snowflake shits
post-tension collapses into peer
shitposting it's boring and immature
like when someone says he wants to watch
the world burn you only get to watch
when you have the privilege of not being
on fire it's edgy but it's not the
darkness the darkness is finding a way
to laugh about being on fire edginess is
always adolescent the darkness is
edginess aged by time and pain and it's
only at that full maturity that comedy
becomes art that it becomes comparable
to music so those are my thoughts like
comment and subscribe the end final sing
the song
I wish my brother George was here hello
darkness my old friend I've come to talk
with you again because a vision softly
creeping left its seeds while I was
sleeping and the vision
[Music]
we feel the sound of silence in Restless
dreams I walked alone narrow streets of
cobblestone Neath the halo of a street
lamp I turned my collar to the cold
[Music]
silence didn't make it light I saw
10,000 people maybe more
people talking without speaking people
hearing without listening people writing
[Music]
disturb the sound of silence stay
gorgeous
[Music]